[Music]
on this sunday night
joe biden sets the tone for his
administration
the transition of power in the white
house let's give each other a chance
as donald trump kicks off a legal battle
refusing to budge
the impact of the incoming president on
canada's energy sector
this is jeopardy and alex trebek
the canadian host of jeopardy loses his
fight with cancer
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us joe biden is setting out to build
bridges in a divided america
but the president-elect has a lot of
work ahead of him to win over the more
than
70 million americans who voted for
donald trump
with kamala harris working alongside him
biden has the monumental task of
tackling
the worsening kova 19 pandemic which the
trump administration has been accused of
mishandling
we begin tonight with mike armstrong on
a country
in transition
the president-elect started his day
attending church with his daughter
and grandson the morning after
delivering the biggest
speech of his life
joe biden's victory speech made it clear
one of the first things he wants to do
is turn down the heat let's give each
other a chance
biden is calling for an era of openness
and respect
it's time to put away the harsh rhetoric
lower the temperature see each other
again
listen to each other again this was a
night where biden claimed victory with
pride but without boasting instead
repeating a campaign promise
to govern for all americans including
those who didn't vote
for him let this grim here of
demonization in america
begin to end here and now
thank you good evening for the vice
president-elect a part of the focus was
on what the election
meant how it reinforced the united
states as a country of possibilities
one where the daughter of an indian
immigrant can be elected vice president
but while i may be the first woman in
this office
i will not be the last
now it may have taken days before the
election was called for biden and harris
but the celebrating will be
short as of monday they're set to start
tackling what will be the biggest
challenge once they take over the
pandemic
according to reports the first order of
business comes
monday the transition team is set to
name a 12-member coronavirus
task force this country is hitting new
records
daily they've averaged more than 100 000
new cases a day
for a week they've had more than 120 000
new cases for three days running
now new cases are one thing but there
are now predictions the number of
hospitalizations
is about to explode robin our mike
armstrong in philadelphia tonight thanks
mike
the sitting u.s president donald trump
has not conceded this election
today he made more claims in tweets
about the election being stolen from him
then he hit the golf course while his
legal team is working on preventing him
from being a one
and done president here's jennifer
johnson
as americans celebrate president-elect
joe biden's win outside the white house
u.s president donald trump played golf
for a second day
behind the scenes trump and his campaign
have launched an all-out war
to reverse the ballot counts it was time
for the president to turn
this discussion over to his lawyers time
for the lawyers to make the case that
they have
both in court and to the american people
and
then we're going to have to deal with
those facts as they're presented
the president has repeatedly made claims
of widespread voter fraud without any
evidence
launching this election defense site to
raise money for his legal fight
the campaign is also asking supporters
to take to the streets in protest
i'm upset about these votes i know
there's a bunch of voter fraud going on
and i think
people need to step up and i think it
needs to be a fair election
the president sent out a barrage of
tweets sunday one saying we believe
these people are thieves
the big city machines are corrupt this
was a stolen election
some republican leaders aren't buying it
when you say that the election was
corrupt
or stolen or rigged but that's
unfortunately
rhetoric that gets picked up by
authoritarians around the world
and i think it also discourages
confidence in our democratic process
here at home
but america's top two republicans house
minority leader kevin mccarthy
and senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell are refusing to criticize
the president's inflammatory words
you're going to have
contests you're going to have court
decisions
that's how we settle these kinds of
disputes in this country
judges in several states will hear
arguments from trump campaign lawyers
starting monday and that includes a case
filed with the u.s supreme court
but most legal experts say these
lawsuits are a long shot
in changing the outcome of the election
robin
jennifer johnson in washington thanks
jen canada u.s relations will no doubt
be different from the last four years
joe biden and justin trudeau may have
more in common
politically but there are differences
when it comes to policy
as abigail beeman reports they may not
see eye to eye on protectionism
and energy tonight the whole world is
watching america
joe biden has made it clear he's a
proponent of protectionism a bi-american
man
the canadian government has a plan for
that making sure that uh
this this space the north american space
you know that we start talking about
buying north america
in an interview on the west block with
mercedes stevenson
foreign affairs minister francois
philippe champagne said
canada will work to foster cooperation
focused on the covet 19 response
the economy and climate change biden is
going to be a green president
so i don't know what happens in the
energy industry at issue
the future of the keystone xl pipeline a
project worth billions to transport up
to 830 000 barrels of oil a day
from alberta to nebraska then connecting
on to the u.s gulf coast
i've been against keystone from the
beginning it is
tar sands that we don't need ottawa and
alberta will keep pushing in the face of
biden's promise to quash it
we'll certainly make the case that
canada has been and remains
the most trusted energy supplier to the
united states
that we will want to work with them that
we have a price on carbon we're going to
zero neutral by
2050. in a statement after biden's win
alberta premier jason kenney was blunt
u.s energy security is dependent on
alberta much of the american economy is
fueled by alberta energy
there may be room for compromise on
there on that i
i i guess we'll have to wait and see
it'll certainly test the skills
of both the alberta and federal
governments we should work together on
cleaner air
cleaner water and cleaner traditional
energies i think we need a broader
discussion
on the united states joining the paris
accord
energy and the environment former
manitoba premier
and canadian ambassador to the u.s gary
dewer points out
biden's journey to the white house was
boosted by the construction trades in
states he was able to flip
right across the canadian border and
building trades have a lot of jobs
invested in that pipeline
abigail beeman global news ottawa
every u.s election is watched closely
around the world
a joe biden presidency could mark a
significant shift in geopolitics
tonight redmond shannon takes a look at
how the result is being received
around the globe
not a protest but a celebration in the
ancestral
indian village of vice president-elect
kamala harris
i knew she was going to win so i was not
tense except
i wanted the final result to come in so
that i can go and sleep
after several days of uncertainty joe
biden emerges victorious as the 46th
president-elect
polls suggested a preference for the
biden harris ticket across
much of the world particularly in europe
us president biden and sanfitsa harrison
where there's a feeling among some
that biden had one undeniable quality
he was an uninspiring candidate but his
biggest inspiration
was he wasn't donald trump among the
world leaders tweeting their
congratulations to joe biden
is british prime minister and friend and
ally of donald trump boris johnson
the outgoing u.s president has been a
big fan of brexit
and johnson had been pinning his hopes
on trump's promise of a post-brexit free
trade agreement
but biden an irish american has insisted
there will be no free trade deal if
brexit results in the return of a hard
border in ireland
period we've even said that we would
never put any infrastructure at the
border between
uh the north and the south and of course
if the eu do the same this issue is
resolved
the biden presidency may change the
dynamics of the uk
eu negotiations that are coming to a
head this month
i am confident the deal can still be
done
another friend of trump's is israeli
leader benjamin netanyahu
partly because trump moved the u.s
embassy from tel aviv to jerusalem
and withdrew the u.s from the iran
nuclear deal
netanyahu called biden a friend of
israel sunday
despite a promise from biden that he
will bring the u.s
back into the deal in a tweet iran's
foreign minister encouraged biden and
harris to
abandon the disastrous lawless bullying
of the outgoing regime washington's
other greatest adversaries russia and
china have yet to formally acknowledge
biden's win
redmond shannon global news london
now to the pandemic it's hard to hear
the numbers but the reality is that
cases are spiking across canada
for a second straight day ontario
reported another record high
more than 1300 new cases in just 24
hours
and 13 more deaths there are nearly 1400
cases in quebec
the province's highest daily total
manitoba has more than 400 new cases
saskatchewan has a daily high of 159 new
cases
and alberta has 727.
tonight manitoba's health minister is
calling for an investigation
into two long-term care homes dealing
with outbreaks one is the maple's
long-term care home
where 22 people have died since a coven
19 outbreak
was declared less than a week ago seven
people have died at the care home in the
last
48 hours paramedics were called in to
treat a dozen people on friday night but
at least two people died
before they got there there are a lot of
people
undertaking to understand more what
occurred at maples
what changed so very quickly that it was
necessary to call paramedics
we're being told by those on site that
they're seeing things in terms of the
condition of patients
they've never seen before in their
careers
the health minister is now calling for a
task force specific
to long-term care homes a rapid response
team is on site
and 20 red cross personnel are being
deployed to the home
coming up he died but they voted him in
any way we'll explain when global
national continues
well there's an interesting election
result in north dakota
david endull a popular republican
candidate
has been elected to the state
legislature but the 55-year-old
died of coven 19 weeks ago heather yorks
west explains
politically north dakota is as red as it
comes
republican support in these parts is a
given
it's just the loyalty party loyalty so
it comes as little surprise that voters
in north dakota
voted overwhelmingly tuesday to elect a
republican
candidate even though he was dead
well in district 8 here unfortunately
one of the candidates died
and he died after the ballot had been
printed so his name could not be removed
from the ballot
55 year old rancher david and dahl died
of covet 19 on october 5th
he was very cautious especially because
he did have a few health challenges
but he was unable to fend off this
disease his family wrote in a facebook
post
covet 19 activity is surging in this
state north dakota has a population
of a little more than 750 thousand
people
and yet it's seeing more than 1500 new
infections
every day it's scary in my opinion
i don't get out too much being retired
you know i can stay home
walk the dog north dakota has the
highest case count per capita
in the country but there are no mandated
restrictions and no statewide
requirements to wear
masks andel's death leaves a vacancy in
north dakota's newly elected house
we haven't experienced that situation
before in our
recollection so it
obviously created a question how do we
go how do they proceed
bjornsson says it's likely the state's
republican committee will be able to
appoint a new candidate to take on del
set
yet another situation without precedent
in an election
unlike anything this country has ever
seen
heather yurix west global news bismarck
north dakota
still ahead the stories from survivors
and the canadians
who saved them
you're watching global national
in 1945 canada helped free the
netherlands from nazi occupation
now a new documentary called 75 years
later the sounds of freedom
shows how that liberation developed into
a deep bond between the two countries
dutch survivors living in canada and
canadian veterans reflect on the horrors
and heroism they witnessed
camp westerbork has a dark history it
was run by the nazis during the second
world war a detention center
for a hundred thousand people mostly
jews
who were put on the trains and deported
to the concentration camps
across the street from us there was a
jewish family
who had a little shop there and one
morning you wake up and there's a big
seal on the door so you know they've
gone
and in the beginning of course you
didn't know anything about the gas
chambers in concentration camps you just
knew that they were
sent through a camp you know a spirit of
wild fiesta reigns in towns and villages
freed by the canadian drive
survivors only learned the true scope of
what the nazis had done
after the liberation of the netherlands
but the nazis were desperate to destroy
the evidence the germans were
so busy they were burning things vapers
burning and everything
they were all everywhere little fires
and the germans disappeared in april
1945 canadian soldiers came in and saved
those who were still at camp westerborg
it was difficult to witness the hunger
and desperation
when you see people that
are starving that have
no source of sustenance
even to the point the way they eat
tulip bulbs that is
something that when you experience it
you never forget it veteran charles
goodman returned
decades later on the 70th anniversary of
the liberation
this dutchman rushed over and classed me
and kissed me in each
cheek and he was crying
and he said he was four years old
when he and his father and his mother
were put into that camp and we saved
their lives
[Music]
but canadian soldiers lost their lives
fighting for freedom in the netherlands
they were buried there and their graves
are still cared for
dutch survivors who immigrated to canada
make a point of returning and visiting
the rose upon rose to see these
endless rows of graves
and you know stones or crosses
with the names of canadian soldiers and
these young boys were 22 to 25 years old
and to think that they had come to
liberate us today camp westerborg is a
commemoration center to remind the world
of the atrocities
the rail lines however have been
destroyed so that no
trains can ever follow that route again
up next who is alex trebek remembering
the canadian game show host who changed
the face
of television
canadian hockey legend and broadcaster
howie meeker has died
after signing on to the toronto maple
leafs in the 1940s meeker helped the
team win
four nhl championships he retired from
hockey in 1969 but became a broadcaster
for hockey night in canada
meeker was inducted into the hockey hall
of fame and received the order of canada
he was 97.
it's hard to categorize the loss of alex
trebek for close to 40 years
the canadian hosted a quiz show with
obscure facts
and today he lost his battle with
pancreatic cancer
here's mike jolet with a look back at
trebek's career
this is jeopardy
[Music]
for over three decades that familiar
jingle meant only one person would walk
out onto the jeopardy stage
here is the host of jeopardy alex
the sudbury ontario native was the
no-nonsense host that turned a popular
game show into a ratings powerhouse
good luck here we go and while alex
trebek became one of the most beloved
hosts in u.s television history
he never forgot where he came from
insisting on at least one question every
show that
referenced canada often times to the
detriment of the american contestants
residents of this saskatchewan city are
called
muscavians randy what is winnipeg
no what is moose job
he launched his career on canadian
television in the 1960s
there was never a question he would be a
game show host
cheer up gene it's only another 18. i'm
it was which show would catapult him to
stardom in 1984 he shot the pilot for
jeopardy
unlike other fair on tv at the time it
was a show that made the audience
think and while his dry wit and
unflappable persona
made him an easy target to parody state
your name
in that category all you need to do is
state your name
nobody had more fun poking fun at alex
trebek
there were women here in
jeopardy then alex trebek he had more
than 40 screen credits in his career
all of them playing some version of
himself you bet at all cliff why would
you do something like that
still he rarely showed his true
personality on screen
yet he was also very open about his
struggles in life
including his final one i have some news
to share with all of you when he was
diagnosed with stage four pancreatic
cancer
he wanted to be the one to inform his
fans vowing to fight in that very alex
trebek way
truth told i have to because under the
terms of my contract
i have to host jeopardy for three more
years
he was 80 years old when the cancer
finally beat him
he taped his last show only a week and a
half ago but many of his canadian fans
will remember this
as his last appearance on tv the correct
response
who is tim stutzel his legacy will
always be
tied to jeopardy the answer to who he
was in the form of a question
who was the incomparable alex trebek
mike global news
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with some moments
from jeopardy as we all remember
alex trebek good night any family
members
back home cheering you on you know
here's a true story man
i grew up i learned english because of
you and so
my grandfather who who raised me i'm
going to get tears right now he
we i used to sit on his lap and watch
you every day did you come up with the
right one
no what is we love you out that's very
kind
thank you
19.95 you're left with five bucks okay